if you let's start with just kind of
quick to three minutes on your
background and kind of what gives you
the perspective that you have for kind
of these types of events yeah so my
background is I started in the finance
industry back in 1990 straight into a
recession scramble around to get a job
couldn't get a job at an investment bank
had a pretty shitty degree and so I got
into a comfortable Dow Jones telerate
which the information provider and my
first job was custom support teaching
people know helping people that with a
technical analysis product so I had to
learn what technical analysis was
because that's train these guys I don't
know anything about them about it so I
started learning about technical
analysis and realize that okay that was
quite interesting I could figure out
what was going on in financial markets
with a few charts then I might have
talked my way into company called James
K Porter's PARP HSBC in equity
derivatives and six months later I was
running the desk then I went to another
UK bank and end up at Goldman where I
started and managed the hedge fund sales
business in equities knackery
derivatives right in line for the Asian
crisis which was a incredible moment in
time then after that I thought that the
recession was coming in 2000 and I
thought the better opportunity was to go
to trade instead so I went to the I
started the global macro fund for the
biggest hedge fund firm in Europe at the
time called GOG Partners got that
recession traded all that whole period
and then decided to opt out of the rat
race and retire to Spain back in 2005
where I started writing macroeconomic
investment strategy research because
I've been in the hedge fund and around
the hedge fund industry for longer than
most people you know my entire career
was speaking to the most famous hedge
fund managers in the world on a daily
basis whether it's Paul Tudor Jones Stan
Druckenmiller there's bacon all of these
guys so I get some learn how they did
things I saw almost every trade every
one of these guys did over the Asian
crisis which is phenomenal because then
I really understood how they put
together a macro view
and just to see them implement trades in
different ways and across continents
across asset classes and layer into it
all of that stuff with fascinating the
whole thing was reading like a picture
for me it's basically a crash course and
what are the richest most successful
people in the world do when everyone
else is running here's how these guys
are navigating these markets and how
they're profiting in many cases yeah
this stuff happens yeah because they
actually counter to the narrative the
really big money is to be made at cycle
turning points and the most money of all
is the down cycle and the reason is is
because the up cycle can take ten years
like we just had and the down cycle
usually comes in eighteen months so the
compressed amount of returns that you
can get if you can short things or take
advantage of that move up in bonds for
example is truly extraordinary so I
asked mark usko who obviously know
pretty well one time I said what
separates the top five investors in each
asset class from the really really good
one so kind of the absolute best at
their craft versus everyone else and
what he said to me is they cut their
losers faster than everyone else and
they press the winners horror than every
clip and I don't agree you don't agree
on that why because people like Nick rad
DT people don't know he's below the
radar screen was probably the greatest
macro trader of all time he didn't do
that okay he had enormous stomach for
risk what he had was his
he had behaviors him he had better
understanding in his head of the
outcomes and therefore he could have
ascertained the risk/reward so he would
suffer more significant drawdowns than
anybody else could suffer but he would
make higher returns and he made more
return to the stand Druckenmiller more
returns than george soros
really at when he was working for Soros
Wow
most people don't realize that but in
general speaking for most people most
people don't have that skill set of
course you know so generally speaking
cut your losses run your winners of
course that's and that's a very flippant
saying because actually not that easy to
do yeah of course it's actually
difficult not to cut your winners what
what is your current portfolio look like
just so as we get into this people kind
understand how you're actually
allocating your capital yeah so my
personal capital is allocated to bonds I
got close some of the position recently
it is dollars it is gold and it's
Bitcoin it's a pretty defensive
portfolio and I don't think of in those
terms I think of what I'm thinking of
these bonds I think you can make
extraordinaire and money and I've
written about Twitter on Twitter and I
retweeted recently about the greatest
trader ever saw it happened in 2001 when
I was trading and how similar the setup
was to today explain their story that
story is a story of a guy working for a
giant hedge fund in London and
the Fed cut and almost identical that
backdrop to today - the virus right so
we were going to an economic slowdown it
was pretty clear the Fed had to cut the
markets the bond market starts pricing
and fed cuts so the Fed then do a cut on
I think it was January the third
everyone still on holiday but this guy
comes into the office of this hedge fund
outside London and he goes limit long
according to his risk guidelines
Eurodollar futures expiring that year
Eurodollar futures are interest rate
three-month interest rate futures so he
was betting that interest rates were
gonna get cut significantly and he gets
on a plane and he goes to his house in
New Yorker and stays there and because
he can't take any more risk he's got one
trade off and his view is we're going to
recession the stock market is in a
bubble the federer gonna have to cut
significantly and the outs the downside
of the stock market bubble unwinding is
the economy goes into recession that was
cool
so he didn't come back to the office and
eventually there was a pickup in rates
as people started fading that narrative
and thinking growth was coming back
which is exactly what we got in
September October November the ship's
exactly the same in fact the both charts
map each other perfectly the most
perfect maps I've ever seen is now
versus them so his boss one of the most
famous hedge fund managers in the world
one of the best risk takers of all time
calls him in and goes so you've given
back a load of money you've made more
money than any other trader of the firm
but you've given back a lot what do you
want to do and I said I want to double
up really
and the guy said why he goes because my
case is still valid and I've got profits
and it's my risk to run and the guy said
fine do it because he understood that
the guy had the clarity does that moment
in time when you have the clarity and he
had the clarity and he went back to me
Orca and the reason I was in my Orca was
simple is he didn't want or wish to call
him his friends to call him or anybody
to persuade you to get out of the trade
yep and he then returned in November
closed the trade and retired do we know
what the return was he made I believe
for himself two hundred million two
hundred million it's not a bad day but
again I don't know quite the numbers and
I won't mention his name because he had
a private guy but phenomenal and that
was one trade one trade ad close was it
when you look at that trade - today is
the same opportunity available we've
just had it so it's been tweeting and
talking and shouting and screaming to
everybody about this because there's a
moment in time when look this part of
the cycle is why do I'm really good at
this doesn't mean I'm always ride as a
minimum [ __ ] but I'm good at this and
I knew that the cycle was turning and we
had a shot in 2016 when we had a almost
a recession we had the manufacturing
recession but it didn't follow through
but this time we looked like the stars
were aligned and the Fed we're going to
cut so I started that whole thing by May
with the Eurodollar futures and then by
August I was pounding the table and
screaming and shouting I remember and
then it basically came